i was actually out having dinner um with
some friends
and um i got a phone call from my dad
and um
we have an agreement where that if you
ring once you're just calling for a chat
you're ringing twice or more then i know
there's something wrong and i need to
actually stop what i'm doing so
the phone was ringing and i answered the
phone and
i heard his voice and i just said
straight away like who's died
do you remember the moment when you
decided you wanted to
become a doctor i remember watching the
early versions 24 hours in amy so
kind of city hospital and these shows
and really thinking
i love the idea of working in a in a
field that has the adrenaline
um you combine like science with kind of
people skills teamwork to
you know basically have an opportunity
to save people's lives you know that's
what it comes down to and
and that really excited me and i was
probably only like 12 or 13 at the time
and i really locked in on that idea i
didn't know if i could ever make it
you know i'm dyslexic and i would say
you know i
lacked a lot of confidence when i was
younger wasn't the loudest of kids
i'm naturally an introvert but i thought
you know what i'm going to do this and i
give it my best shot
so how did an introverted medicine
graduate end up on love island
that is a very good question you know
when i was at med school i had a really
close friend called freya
uh she was the most amazing person you
know like kind of the perfect
uh doctor to be um did loads of charity
work was passionate about you know
well-being and worked so hard but in the
second year she
um she sadly got leukemia she eventually
had a bone marrow transplant came out
but unfortunately a couple of months
later she went
back she the cancer came back and
and she was told there's nothing more
that they could do
and um a week or so before she passed
she
sat me down and we all kind of said
goodbyes really to her
and she said alex you know i'm at the
point where i'm at the end of my life
now
and um i can't do all the things i want
to do so
i really want you to go out there as
you're naturally an introvert go out
there and take opportunities and don't
be afraid of life's challenges and i
think
when i was faced with that situation and
i had that phone call from the itv
exec saying we want you to actually
start on the show i thought
i think this is the kind of situation
she was talking about so i went for it
what was the experience like once you
got into that
i think it was quite hard actually in
the villa and i think people see it as
like this glossy place and
you know it's um you know lying there
sipping cocktails and stuff but in
reality you're filming for
i don't know like 16 17 hours a day but
i did enjoy it it was an incredible
experience and there's certainly pinch
me moments
sitting you know having a date in the
garden and you know you've got everyone
around you
um you know from the cameraman to the
team there and you're aware that you
know this has gone out to so many people
we think wow
what an experience in
there for you life while you were
filming to protect you
i think i was very fortunate on the show
that um there was amazing producers
there and
i think the whole team was in it
together like even though you're filming
and you're
you're creating a show there is a sense
of family because you're out there for
like eight or nine weeks
if you're there the whole time but it
was tough i mean there were real
highs and real lows as well i think when
i left the show
i think itv did pretty good job you know
i i reached out to them and said look
it's been a huge life shift you know
everything that's happened
and that time is you know it's a lot to
deal with and i saw i got counselling
had therapy for a period of time
and people talk about well did you go
for that because you were feeling bad
are you feeling sad
um i think there was times when i found
it pretty stressful but
more than anything i just realized that
whenever you have a big life experience
you probably should talk about it
especially what's happened and some of
the you know sad losses of life we've
had
post love island and for people that
have been associated with the show
and i'm really glad to see that you know
broadcasters like itv are taking this
quite seriously
and focusing on their care and aftercare
for people that have been on the show
what motivated you to carry on being an
nhs doctor
rather than going down like a more
traditional post-reality
life i think in life everyone needs the
field purpose
and um to me i feel that being a doctor
gives me that purpose given that role
like i know who i am in that role
and the best thing i ever did was going
back to a e i never had any other
intention actually i was always people
always quite surprised when i said i'm
gonna go back to work
like really and but it was an obvious
thing for me to do
why not my colleagues welcomed me back
as if it was yesterday and i think that
for me was
a sense of belonging and being there to
try and
do something positive has helped me ever
since and it's it will always remain
part of who i am whatever happens when
you carried on working at local hospital
what was it like
being on the front line there's no
manual for kobe 19.
um it wasn't at med school you know yeah
of course we were taught about preparing
for pandemics and infection control but
this was something brand new
and so um you know looking back it was
it was tough because a lot of things we
know now
only a year on from covid if i'd have
known then we would have saved i think
more lives
there's no doubt that the pandemics had
a huge impact on everyone's mental
health and
even though there's a real negative side
of course um you know we've been away
from family and friends
changes to our relate you know
relationships workplace
sadly some people living losing loved
ones there's also been an opportunity
we've all
had a chance to reflect on what really
matters and to think about our
health and happiness and our mental
well-being
and now more than ever in history i'd
have thought
people are just so much more aware of
how important mental health actually is
that we need to tackle stigma that we
need to make sure that we fund and
resource
our mental health services properly and
also that we have a really stark
realization that
mental health is in a crisis in this
country in july last year you lost your
brother to suicide can you
talk us through what happened in the
moment you found out
i was actually out having dinner um with
some friends
and um i got a phone call from my dad
and um
we have an agreement where because i do
a lot of things like sitting here
filming
and that if you ring once you're just
calling for a chat you're ringing twice
or more then i know there's something
wrong and i need to actually stop what
i'm doing so
the phone was ringing and i answered the
phone and
i heard his voice and i just said
straight away like who's died because
you there's only
you just know um and he said that was it
was clear
and my immediate thought was whether
he'd had you know a heart problem or
he had an accident or whatever um and
then you know i left the restaurant and
went
went home and then i that he explained
what had actually happened and
yeah it's the most difficult thing to
hear you know clear is 10 years younger
than me
mini me in every way had a place at med
school
in stampton and yeah it was it was just
a huge shock
were there any signs that he displayed
that he was struggling with mental
health
nothing that i would say would be any
more than what you'd expect for
you know an 18 19 year old who's been
locked up for a long time
he's a bit anxious about his exam
results coming up um
but very inwardly uh kind of
hiding the stuff like he never really
expressed to me that he he certainly
didn't express to me he felt that way
and obviously a huge regret for me in
the family is that we never
realized i guess um with hindsight it's
always easy to look back and like oh
gosh there's a few little things but
in reality you never expect that to
happen to your
i think how am i dealing with the grief
i think it's probably better it's uh
it's an ongoing uh it's an ongoing thing
i i
i see it as there's a it's a black box
that's uh in your head and
when it first happens you're staring
into the box the whole time
and as time goes on you're able to kind
of put the box on the side of the room
and then eventually you can close the
lid and
hopefully one day i can put it on the
shelf and it but it will always sit
there it'll always be in that house
first in the morning and lasting at
night i do think about him every day and
i don't think that will ever stop
um and sometimes you get flashes of
thoughts into your head
when you're going about your day yes
it is something that's very difficult to
process but in many ways i think that
my life will always now be like pre and
post
and i think when you go through
something like that it does change you
you're never
the same um after that kind of
experience but
you know i have to you have to keep
going um
you know i think even a couple of weeks
after i had to pick myself up for my
family and my friends and say you know
we have to move forward
um you know grief will be forever we'll
be grieving forever
um but we have to kind of pick ourselves
up and
do it for him really it's something that
i think i'll continue to have to manage
the rest of my life but if i can do
something positive
off the back of it that's exactly why
i'm doing the work i'm doing now
and then i feel that i can never get him
back but if i can prevent other families
going through that
because it is the worst pain imaginable
i can't really imagine much worse
um you know it is it is that worse when
you talk about the worst case scenario
it is that worst case scenario
i think it makes you think about what
what matters in life and my values and
the things that bother me now
um have been decreased so much i mean
you know i care about my family my
friends
i care about you know the work that i'm
doing as a doctor the
the the campaign that i'm doing but a
lot of the little things now just don't
really bother me much
anymore and i would say i'm so much
tougher and more resilient i think in in
in many ways but but at the same time
um much more open and and sensitive in a
way
and i think part of being tough or
resilient
is being able to be aware of your own
emotions being able to ask people for
help and
being able to do the things that that
keep you feeling well it's not about
being stoic
in inward and what would you say to
someone struggling with mental health
just know that people care you know
people do genuinely care you know i care
and so please do reach out and don't be
afraid to to say that you're struggling
because
i don't know anyone in life that's gone
through life with this kind of perfect
um time of no struggles and 10 out of 10
happiness this just just doesn't
exist we all have ups and downs and when
you're feeling a down
reach out get support
and then literally my now just mandy
break right and i i slammed my throttle
fully forward really quickly i just
rolled to 120 degrees
i pulled really really hard towards the
ground he immediately
started pumping out flares and they act
as a decoy to the surface-to-air missile
that had just launched and it had
locked onto my engines